تتحول الان الى مطار الرباط
وصور مباشره لوصول المنتخب المغربي وذلك
بعد تحقيقه المركز الرابع في كاس العالم
20022 في قطر
[موسيقى]
طيب يبدو ان مراسلنا معنا ينضم الينا من
الرباط المختار العلاوي المختار ضعنا في
الاجواء والمشهد لديك
نعم اجواء تاريخيه الجمهور المغربي يقول
شكرا لك ايها المنتخب المغربي شكرا لكم
اسود الاطلس على الانجاز الذي تم تحقيقه
في مونديال قطر عشرات الالاف البعض يقول
مئات الالاف هذه هي الجماهير المغربيه
التي حجت الى شوارع العاصمه المغربيه
الرباط من اجل تقديم الشكر والاحتفال
باجاز المنتخب المغربي اجراءات امنيه
مجدده حوالي ثمانيه الاف شرطي تم نشرها من
اجل ضمان سلامه موكب الاسود العديد من
الشوارع الشوارع العاصمه بالتحديد توقفت
فيها الحركه ومنع فيها ايضا توقف الحركات
توقف السيارات في انتظار وصول موكب اسود
الاطلس موكب الاسود الاطلس الذين وصلوا
قبل قليل الى مطار سلا الرباط سيصلون بعد
دقائق من الان الى هذا المكان الى شارع
الحسن الثاني حيث سيبدا الموكب في تحيه
الجماهير مرورا بعدد من الشوارع في
العاصمه من بينها ساحه الملك حسين وساحه
الملك محمد الخامس بالاضافه الى شوارع
اخرى وصولا الى القصر الملكي حيث سيكون
هناك استقبال رسمي لاسود الاطلس بيان
لوزاره الاوسمه والقصور الملكيه المغربيه
قال ان هناك استقبال رسمي بعد المسار
المتالق لاسود الاطلس في مونديال قطر اسود
الاطلس كانوا اول فريق او اول منتخب عربي
وافريقي يصل الى دور نصف النهايه وبقليل
من الحظ كان بالامكان الوصول الى مباراه
النهائيه لكن على اي الجمهور المغربي سعيد
جدا بهذا المنتخب بهذا الفريق الشاب الذي
يقول الخبراء والمتابعون انه سيكون له شان
كبير خصوصا وان عناصره اغلب عناصره لا
زالت شابه بقياده مدرب شاب هو وليد
الركراكي الذي اعطى اضافه نوعيه لهذا
المنتخب المنتخب المغربي لم يكن فقط يمثل
المغرب بيمثل العرب ومثل الافارقه ومتى
لايضا الشعوب المستضعفه التي تابعه في
اسيا وفي افريقيا همم المباريات التي
خاضها المنتخب المغربي والذي تمكن من
الفوز على منتخبات عريقه كان المنتخب
البلجيكي المنتخب البرتغالي كالمنتخب
الاسباني قبل ان يتوقف مسار منتخب المغربي
في دور نصف النهايه بعد ان خرج في مباراه
نصف المنتخب الفرنسي هذا المنتخب بالاضافه
الى كره القدم اعاده مجموعه من القيم الى
الشباب عرف في الصحافه المغربيه والصحافه
العربيه بانه منتخب الساجدين راينا وشهدنا
علاقات اللاعب بوالديه بامه بئر الوالدين
ايضا كلمه ركز عليها مدرب المنتخب المغربي
وليد الرجراجي وهي النيه ضروره الاخلاص من
اجل تحقيق نتائج وهذا ما تحدث في هذا
المونديال المونديال قطر الذي عرف الكثير
منها الانجازات والذي شهد به شهد العالم
بنجحه على كافه المستويات اذا هذا الجمهور
الذي حج ليس فقط من الرباط وليس من مدينه
سلا المجاوره بل بل الجمهور حجه من مدن
مختلفه همم التقينا ببعض الجمهور الذين
جاءوا من مدينه طنجه من مدينه القنيطره من
مدينه الخميسات من مختلف المدن المغربيه
يحج هؤلاء الى هنا الى شارع الحسن الثاني
من اجل تحيه المنتخب المغربي الذي وصل قبل
قليل الى مطار الرباط سلا خادما من مطار
حمد الدولي في رحله استمرت حوالي سبع
ساعات
والان بعد لقاء اللاعبين في مطار سلا
الدولي بافراد عائلتهم
سايركبون حافله مكشوفه وستجوب شوارع
العاصمه المغربيه وستكون هناك مجموعه من
الانشطه والتعاليات لتحيه الاسود على هذا
الانجاز الذي همم وكان غير مسبوقه هذه
الانجاز الذي وصف في المغرب بالتاريخ
باعتبار ان اخر انجاز للكره المغربيه كان
هو تخطي دور المجموعات في مونديال مكسيكو
سنه 196
80 زي ما هي المغربيه ترفع الاعلام حجه
رفقه افراد عائلتها كبار السن الاطفال
النساء الرجال الكل يحمل الاعلام المغربيه
ويرتدون همم قمصان المنتخب المغربي هذا
المنتخب الذي كما شاهدنا طيله تغطيه قناه
الجزيره لمونديال قطر ادخل الفرحه على
فئات مختلفه من المجتمع المغربي الكل كان
سعيدا بتلك النتائج خصوصا وان اكثر
المتفائلين كانوا يتوقعون وصول المنتخب
المغربي الى همم تخطيه دور المجموعات ولم
يكن اكثر المتفائلين يتوقع ان يصل المنتخب
المغربي الى دور نصف النهايه واقصاء
منتخبات عريقه المنتخب الاسباني والمنتخب
البرتغالي هذه المنتخبات كانت مرشحه للذكر
والفوز بكاس العالم الذي نظم في مونديال
قطر
2002 و20 وثمان واحد الان
تواجد الناس قادمين من مدينه سلا ومن مدن
مغربيه في انتظار وصول حافله المنتخب
المغربي من هذا الاتجاه الى شارع نعم
كبير
وهم يستحقون هذا الاستقبال الجماهيري
الكبير بفعل البطوله التي اظهرها في هذه
في هذا الموضوع شكرا لك المختار العبلاوي
كنت معنا من الرباط